welcome everyone to pogchamps i'm
alexandra live with international master
levy rosman
and the biggest chess streamer on all of
twitch
ludwig great to have you guys levy do
you want to start off with your thoughts
on
call me carson and gripex match uh my my
thoughts don't even
have to have a place we're we're just
off um
how are we gonna how are we gonna get
first of all ludwig um we usually see
cutie cinderella uh sitting there what's
the please
what's going on look i just wasn't the
biggest fan of her meatloaf and i just
have slept here the whole night but i'm
ready to
commentate some great chess between
colley carson and gripex
which which i'm thoroughly excited for
okay
because uh carson hasn't got a dub yet
like me and twitch rivals but we'll get
there yeah
i got there before you so you can't even
do it now i that you did be
rabbit yourself which is upsetting
because i was gonna spend the next three
hours
just roasting your team um but you know
what
we'll we'll we'll have to ignore it for
now uh yeah
yeah i think he hasn't had a dub yet and
uh you know
that you want to get one at some point
right he's gone o2 every game so far
every tournament match
he has and he doesn't have an easy
opponent either because gripex
is leading group a in sec well not
leading he's second place
and he's higher rated so any strats you
think he can go for a lettering
no no that's the thing about chess
is that that doesn't you can't cheese
them
if they're you know what i mean like you
can cheese at 800 if you're 400 you just
i feel like you can't really cheese a
uh if you're 600. i just don't know how
it's done he's
playing pretty well uh sicilian out the
gate
some chances for uh gripex to take
advantage but gripex is super solid
and yes for the moment he is not
he's not in the lead in this group but
if he gets the three points today he
does win it because we saw
earlier that foursome beats scissors
what are you
what do you make of that alexandra like
scissors
going into consolation bracket forsen
into the champions bracket what
what's that going to mean in terms of
their chances because they're group a so
they play group b
which we're going to see later but you
know hafu
hackman easy with aces etc
honestly it's not the worst outcome
for scissors i mean we actually have
someone in the call who can relate
to uh making it in the consolation
bracket and then
being in the top two so i would call it
i would call it smart
ethical right live head uh yeah i think
i think it's a it's a good
a good thing for scissors i think uh i
think he's probably the
favorite to win the consolation bracket
i think the only other person will be
whoever doesn't make it out of group c
so either tf blade or one of those three
uh but i think he's a really good shot
and that'll be really exciting for him
rather than just
going there and you know likely
eventually losing to
whoever is in that stressful
[__] show of a championship bracket i've
never been there
so i don't know what it's like but it
seems scary i don't like it
it's definitely intimidating and even in
his match against gripex
scissors was playing super well he only
ended up losing in the armageddon match
because
you know his dog distracted him um but
you know if he gets a dog babysitter i
think the consolation bracket is
definitely
looking like a safe place for him i was
gonna ask
so ludwig made it to the very very final
of the constellation bracket where did
you feel
you ascended the most as a chess player
and as a chess professional as we see
grypic's dead lost he is actually
completely lost
before i even hear i think it wasn't
until bracket because none of
i knew this none of the uh the group
stages really mattered
like after i lost a couple like you know
you're guaranteed to go into losers
he saw it sorry to cut you off there
yeah you're good
you're good carson's making five head
plays i think we need to call them out
yeah that's super impressive so he just
took the bishop on e3 that was
protecting the knight on c5
and if carson follows through then he's
going to be up an entire piece
yeah the only downside is that grip x
will probably play like pawn d4
and then he'll just block up everything
in the center and so carson's gonna have
to get his
like actual bishop that hasn't moved yet
over on c8 out and oh my goodness
what is going on queen flying
everywhere was that the right thing
carson did there
carson played it correctly um he does
have an extra piece yeah
yeah he he did end up with an extra
piece um it was just oh
i'm oh okay yeah well that was crazy hey
for a moment you're like wait how did
carson get so good
oh my gosh oh and now the night is gone
and the bishop has no defense i mean he
had so much time
oh no well that's the thing carson
really impressed me
when i uh watched his match against
was it forsen and then he just makes a
couple blunders but you know what he's
warming up and he seems very focused
today yeah
he just plays incredibly fast though
he does that was like the most
game-changing moves
and and he did them faster than gripex
well let's take a listen and see what he
has to say
[Music]
i love this themed their soundtrack
he just has different changing
backgrounds of minecraft
oh man i was on his main account and he
was listen
and whoever he's hosting is listening to
serial killer role play asmr
i was very confused for a second
i will say a lot of retail room in the
bottom left of his screen
for his notifications to be on his head
yeah but
i'm not gonna judge my fellow peers
he's got an active king this is uh this
is very dangerous though for him
well ludwig what would you say his best
comeback chances are here he's lost a
couple pieces
is there anything he can hope for again
one of the sad things about chess is
there's not a lot of ways to choose
better players
and there's not a huge cut back factor
uh in the game
unless you're dog [__] and unfortunately
grip it's
close but not exactly dog [__]
i think what a call i think that's the
closest thing ludwig has ever gone to a
compliment ladies and gentlemen
not dog [__] wow i was
trying to like replay that in my head
i'm like you said close but not
i think he jess he's just outside the
range
like if there's a barometer of [__] to
hakaru
he's just outside where you probably
can't make a uh
a plus 10 comeback on them very easily
how about
myself and alexandra where are we on the
on the dog [__] meter and let's just
move on to what carson's moves here are
like what's the intent of them you think
uh
he's just trying to survive here i mean
he's down two rooks
i guess he can try to go for a stalemate
and give up part of his queen side
pieces but
the chances aren't looking very good
yeah to get a stalemate obviously all
the pieces have to be
pushed for all his pawns are taken
yeah and they're not and they're really
far away from doing that
so i don't know if he'll live long
enough to see that happen
no probably not now groupix has to be
careful he uh let's just maintain one
well at least he put him out of his
misery you know when you kind of see an
animal living around
don't let it suffer he kind of walked
him into his own mate
yeah carson carson surprises me because
he it's so strange
he plays really well in the opening
and i i don't know if it's if it's like
a little bit of stubbornness like he
thinks like okay this guy's a lot better
than me this whole group is better than
me
i have no chance uh-huh but he played he
was completely winning like
it's just a confidence thing if he just
paused for a second took a breath
and then you know but i mean also
i think opening is where you can be most
comfortable because you will see it more
often
and the deeper into the games you get i
mean what do you call it call
theory right because it's so many
different ways it can go and you stop
tracking the movements of the pieces
so i i think the less games you played
the less confident you'll be
after the first eight moves even if
you're winning you won't know it
well at least if he slows down a little
bit that should help because even
look at the game he had eight minutes
and a half and he started off with 10.
he's blitzing it a little bit too much
here that was impressive
how quickly he lost if we could change
the format to 3-0
i think he'd do really well we just
gotta get him armageddon game every
single time
yeah he should be in business i mean
it'll help him if uh if he goes to the
consolation bracket which i think he
he has to right at this point uh yeah
when he ends up in consolation bracket
uh he probably will find himself in
armageddon and
i think he'll be one of the stronger
players in that format
yeah what do you think carson's chances
are looking like in the consolation
bracket would you put him in the top out
for the bottom half levy
he he can honestly with the openings
that he has he takes like one or two
more lessons and does a few some puzzles
which is
i mean that's a big if it's a big ask
i've been asking
uh connor and austin to just like please
like do one hour
just the focus chess lesson you're gonna
be unstoppable after that but not
everybody
has it uh in their schedule or in their
interest frankly chess is uh
not everybody's cup of tea i think he
could beat
uh a real threat i think he could beat
maybe even
like a scissors or a uh you know
definitely austin or conor i think i
think he'll be like slicker you know
there's a chance that he takes down a
big one and maybe
maybe even goes on to the finals
well if if i remember correctly critical
was up against slicker to decide who was
making the finals yeah yeah that's right
right
in the constellation bracket and that
game was crazy like i remember looking
back at that game
there was pandemonium all over the board
there was king walks
yeah pieces flying so the chances for
for winner there i don't like that
arson kind of
faded on his on his opening expertise in
the english
like he's trying to build this giant
pawn wall uh-huh
you don't like his giant pow wall not a
huge fan
he did push his f pawn though and you
usually don't want to do that at least
he doesn't have any
serious weaknesses just yet so if he
finds a way to
you know develop his knight from e2 and
the bishop from f1 and castle then i'll
feel like he saved this opening
yeah essentially when you play this
you're trying to avoid
uh well at least when you when you play
this with white you're trying to avoid
putting all the
pawns on the same color square because
like alexander's
just said not about f3 it's also about
all the others you know f3 is
bad but you can make it work maybe but
right now it's
okay well they're just mirroring they're
bearing
uh very close position
ludwig when you were starting off chest
did you ever just try to copy what your
opponent did i'll do you one better i
still
do that i like i think when you play as
black
copying what your opponent does works
like every time until they threaten you
then you just stop
like if you know when to stop it i think
it's fine
i thought you were retired well look
come on levy even a retired man likes to
go down to the new york park every once
in a while
all right that's fair play a few matches
but i think i don't think it's that bad
man
you guys are the ones who should call me
out on this but i think it's fine
and it's you know i think my middle and
end game are more important
than whatever i do in the beginning as
long as i don't do anything super dumb
well unfortunately he broke the mirror
at a point that is better for gripex
because now that bishop on d4
is holding carson's king from castling
and with a move like c6 i guess he'll
retreat his knight back to c3
but no it's going to be you know do you
think he leaves his night there no he
takes the knight
yeah okay and then he'll he'll activate
black's queen a little bit
yeah but you don't think of that it's
more like hey
oh okay oh actually ludwig you were
right there's no way
that was crazy that was crazy
i yeah i'm i'm i'm quite confused
admittedly that made zero
sense but i'm so perplexed because he
spent
27 seconds on that move
uh and then yeah i i don't know look at
the end of the day this match
actually doesn't affect whether carson
will or will not make consolation or
championship bracket
it is purely just a a game
because already owen two in his matches
uh that will help him
one get tournament experience and you
know two
uh just help him get another match
in and so i i don't think it's too fatal
if he's not playing well maybe he's
trying to work on speed or maybe he just
is more aloof
and understands that this guy's going to
be way better than anyone else he plays
for the rest of the tournament which is
true maybe
this will be the best person he plays
should we listen to uh grip x yeah like
he's got the fireplace going
i do win a pawn at the end but let's
just castle first
the way he's toying with carson
scott disick and he's on tmz that's the
kind of media you consume ludwig
this is like a like a like a world
renowned and play you know
man you know maybe he's not known for
the right things but he's known
well i feel like scott disick would also
have this satanic
fire background yeah it almost got me it
actually looked very real
and then i realized that there's a giant
stock logo watermark
right there behind him and it's not real
nothing gets by you levy
nobody's a quick one it looks really
good though i mean it does look pretty
good go for a check here i think it's i
guess this is
also an advert for stockx or whatever
the company
sorry just to cut you off just a quick
analysis it's kind of close to the fire
so it would be very hot anyway back to
you alex what are you thinking about the
game well i was just saying that
now we see the issue with carson not
castling early
he just never ended up getting the
chance and i think that's something a
lot of pogchamps participants fall into
when they just take their time too long
with development
yeah i mean game one and two right as
king went out into the center of the
board
yeah which is not a great place for him
and
it just makes it really easy for your
opponent to win
and one thing that confuses me about
that is i feel like every coach
in the first lessons tells their student
castle the king and then the students
just don't do it
ludwig is this something you ever did in
pogchamp pouring resident sleeper
castling cringe
rather would move up cool strong chad
knight
you're not helping their case wait let's
do this tonight at night
gets to move leave the boring cringe ass
king in the center he's fine there
oh okay so do you move the king into the
center or just leave the king
i don't i you don't touch the king you
move all your cool chad pieces
and then they threaten your king and
then you're like uh oh and then you
have to move up because it's too late
well carson is bringing that chat energy
the way he's just you know
super focused there i don't even need to
be here but i
am no i think he i think he does have to
be here
i i don't well actually it does have to
listen our legal team is he could have
tried to skip it didn't
uh it's one of the reasons we were
featuring uh the match earlier
scheduling is is difficult got all these
different
i gotta tell you look at carson
he is vibing right now
is he listening to a banger i don't know
he just looks
like so stoic and at peace he looks like
he's pretending to be a statue
yeah i don't care if he's not saying
[Music]
anything
shout out to wing chair
[Music]
at least he's trying to go for an attack
here
maybe we'll see some some pond oh not
that not that pawn
not the d-pawn we don't want to open up
the king even more
[Music]
i'm not i'm not joking i aspire to have
this level of just
tranquility uh yeah
[Music]
oh there he is i thank you
okay that met him broke him that broke
him a bit what does that mean oh no
does he realize what does that mean
it means you're in check oh a discovery
check
if i move my rook then i lose i see
what's happening here
i mean none it's illegal holy [__] what
is happening wait
am i in check
that he has i forgot what that meant
that's some high level analysis is that
can you do it in in in land chess can
you make an illegal move and then lose
how does that work does your opponent
have to stop you
they usually tell you you made an
illegal move it's if it's a tournament
game and sometimes they have like
deductions or some kind of penalty if
you do it
and then they just reset the board it's
actually really lame
yeah in slow chess you get a
two minute penalty like in a 90 per
player game
90 minute per player game you get a two
minute penalty i think the second time
according to different countries is
different in in the states
you can be forfeited but like in a
scholastic tournament they will never
forfeit i think you should straight up
lose i think so too is that crazy that's
like hype
it means you found something that they
didn't see and then they made a
fatal mistake on the bat i think you
should be able to capture the king
yeah i think something if you make them
and you can in five minute chests
in in the us if you capture the king
then you usually win right levy
yeah or like an illegal move as the game
is over there is no two minute penalty
you pause the clock and you're just like
yeah
exactly that's cool why don't we get to
capture him kill the king
every time it's like oh all for the king
so many people died on the way to him
and then he just gets what parlay i
don't understand it i want murder
death blood well i'm going to phrase the
email to the us chess federation
slightly differently but i
um send them a clip of ludwig
blood we're going all french revolution
on their dumbasses
i have this problem a lot when i was
doing scholastic programs
i was like walking around the room
seeing you know kids kids playing and
giving feedback
kid would run up to be like i took their
king and i'm like that's you can't do
that like it breaks my heart to say that
i can't just make up a rule
yeah you know so basically everything
you set up child
all this pawns and nights was was for
naught
you don't actually get to capture it
yeah that we just stopped the game now
at the fun part my bad my bad
alexandria your thoughts well speaking
of
stopping the game at the fun part it
looks like gripex is very close to
checkmating carson here
i do like that carson has been putting
in his best effort you know that's a
very active king that isn't just
you know some patrician who sits at home
while his troops do the work
yeah hangs on jesus washington-esque
oh no well oh no
now it's almost checkmate after the king
moves the pawn on g2 is hanging
why rio knowing what's oh no oh no
the king is about to get checkmated
ludwig he can only go to h3
or h4 i guess he can also go to f4 never
mind there are a few options
but they're all bad well the queen was
also captured
but yeah if you just looked at carson
you would never know that that occurred
because there's a minecraft in front of
him i could believe
that right now he was playing minecraft
and not chess
and winning at minecraft oh oh
what was that at least he won a rogue
back and gripex didn't see the checkmate
yeah that was that was weird but i mean
your most active piece cannot be your
king it's chess okay it's not
carson is a content creator
he is creating a new story here for the
king on g5 and
you know he might die in early death but
he's doing it for a good cause
yeah there's a few ways to uh to finish
this off the computer has found
checkmate in six m6
no i have i have not found a mate 6 now
i mean i think go ahead ludwig i'm just
saying saved i mean look the computer
now is down to only minus 20.
only minus 20. that's great news yeah
this is tough i think the more human way
to win this is not to go for the
checkmate and just go collect all the
pieces and it's good that brypex is
doing that because he only has four
minutes so he could potentially sit too
long
try to find a checkmate and end up
getting in time pressure
that move that carson just played might
be the best move that he's played of the
tournament well no last round he played
knight takes bishop and then bishop
takes knight that was
that was incredible that was genius best
move this game though i'm sure
yeah like defended by the pawn attacks
the road now now
graphics doesn't he could just take the
pawn he doesn't really need the rook but
let's see what he does making gripex
think and also carson has managed his
time a lot better this round so now he
has six minute and a half he didn't play
you know the entire game in two minutes
at least there's progress
that's a nice move is carson gonna take
the knight or the rook
take the rook find yourself a back rank
he's going for it unfortunately it'll be
discovered check yeah
okay run the king i mean there is a
faint
hope of a background checkmate
king f4 okay that works as well
again the computer is saying made in two
but it doesn't seem like gripex is out
there searching for a mate
where is this made in two by the way
like i'm i'm really doing my best knight
g2 king g3 where
where what are we looking at where's
this made queen f5
what okay queen f5 doesn't work
queen oh it's queen d6 king g5 and then
queen f6 oh that's very cute
but tough to see although he might take
d6
anyways and then find it because
there's no other move other than king g5
oh he took the rook okay
the back rank the back rank imagine
now it's not even mate because at least
the queen can sacrifice itself oh man
but it's it's there
okay he's just got to move his king over
and then you know
put the rook on an open file and pray
for a back rank
i'd be impressed if carson does end up
going for that tactic even if it doesn't
work at least
it shows that he's going for a
last-ditch effort to win
yeah oh that's it there goes the last
ditch ever
now yeah all right all right
well hey it was on the board for a while
it was and he has made this game
last longer than it likely should have
true
did he make it last longer or did grimex
just decide to play
with his food true well you get you get
to credit both
even if it's not carson's doing he gets
the credit for it
fair enough well grypics
close to two minutes on the clock levy
do you think there's any chance he gets
in time pressure no no
no no no no no no no no no uh yeah
there's a move yeah well the thing is i
actually i was gonna say that there's a
chance that this happens because carson
gets out of check by moving his king
rather than also trying to block with
with pawns
and that's going to get you into trouble
like on bishop f5 he could have maybe
tried to block with the pawn
uh but now you know griffix can blunder
here okay
no no he just he's not
it ain't happening he's not making a
mistake
but carson is seeing the free pieces and
again like ludwig said earlier
he can think of this as a practice round
because it wasn't gonna
affect if he made it into the
championship or consolation bracket
and he's carrying out the end very well
here
ludwig when you're playing in pogchamps
if you lost a game but you felt like
you played the second half well did it
change your mindset at all
if they were better than me and and i
lasted to a certain move i'd
i i'm still popping off i didn't i just
called him turbo verge nerd and
called it that you know what i mean i i
hey i played pretty good
against box box was a turbo virg nerd at
chess when i played him
so that made me feel good about my
performance it didn't make me lose
confidence in my ability
did you score higher than him yesterday
in in rivals
i did i did score higher than him in
rivals
was it his turn to call you a turbo
virgin nerd i was a turbo verge nerd at
follow guys admittedly
he could call me that and i'd have to
take it
wait there might be some stalemate
chances in here that bishop on a8
is kind of hard to yeah he's gonna have
to give it up which is
hard hard to think of even someone in
the chest
uh chest.com game chat said grip's
rating is accurate
he cannot see a basic mate
okay wow that's roasted
you gotta trash talk a little bit right
like you gotta bring these as a chat
member
oh yeah are you kidding me the the game
chat on hikaru versus magnus carlsen was
all 800
saying that this guy's past this prime
this guy's not taking it seriously
they're all acting like disappointed
parents
oh my gosh i imagine
it was fun it was a lot of fun uh that's
mate
on the board oh he didn't see it
just wait to see what those 800s are
going to say in chess.com chat about
that one it's still made in one queen h5
is on the it's just made quick it's mate
oh my god
anymore oh hafu's laughing somewhere
i mean she's like this guy's supposed to
be the favorite along with me come on
he can't even find mate
well he can find it he's just going for
the two queen strat nothing wrong with
that it's clean he's already perfected
it why not
yes very nice much less beautiful but it
did get the job done
a win is a win and uh that's going to
put gripex with
seven points in his group forsen
currently with six so he'll be
making it to the championship bracket he
was already gonna do that but he played
very well even if it wasn't a hundred
percent accurate
yeah i think uh i think we're gonna get
the players in right
and we will take a quick break talk to
gripex i'm gonna try to hype him up get
him to talk some trash because uh
the last matchup of the day today
determines who i think his playoff
seating is against i believe i don't
want to
spoil anything so quick break and we'll
talk to the players
[Music]
welcome back everybody to pogchamps
first match in the books
and we've got our our players here uh
i'm going to start with ludwig actually
he wasn't a plea but he said he was
going to be mean so i'm just going to
turn it over to him look i'm not going
to be mean i'm just going to ask a
couple of questions
to our competitors carson first yes you
are
you're now going to consolation bracket
just tell me
how you feel about your play in the game
of chess do you feel good
do you feel like you know what you're
doing uh no not
generally okay i mean you
did you feel like you did anything good
today do you know what you did that was
good today
not at all great well you did some good
things we'll look at them in a moment
okay scripex you are gonna move on to
the championship bracket
yeah do you feel confident about winning
the whole thing
uh well i always like to be confident so
of course i'm gonna win the whole thing
but yeah there is some competition at
least
you do you do and i think uh i think
it'll definitely be tough
uh there are a few mates you missed i
don't know if you knew that and you're
just trying to get the easy one and
yeah yeah i missed a few i could feel it
but i uh
don't worry about it no stress yeah just
try to get the cause i got under my skin
somehow did you did you know that
i have a thing for that i get under a
lot of people's skins i think
well uh carson you were winning in the
first game i was
well of course so i'm gonna pull it up
on the big screen
uh you you say of course
like like i'm supposed to do this
because it says it on your screen carson
don't say
where where you played into a line
yeah you took a bishop he took back and
then
at the end of everything you've got
three pieces you got two bishops
and a horse you were just winning
griff did you know that you were just
busted here like for a couple months i i
saw him
finding moves i just didn't expect at
all and
i was just so impressed by what i did in
the first game either
this was incredibly five out of you
carson and you had the lead
but it was only for about a turn because
your very next move
you decided to move your rook onto the
e-file which was unprotected a hanging
piece
as soon as you had it you kind of threw
it away but you had it i mean what your
line was
was was insane if you look back at your
line
basically you threatened uh the only
piece that was protecting and then made
him have a hanging bishop and then he
took yes
you played the computer move the
computer move the computer move
did you know you were doing this no yeah
so okay carson here's the thing man
you're gonna go to constellation you're
going to lose this bracket it's just an
inevitability it's how it works
but you're better than a lot of people
there all right
i'm not saying you're the guaranteed one
to win it but i'm saying you can easily
beat people like connor
in austin you have a great chance of
beating people like cutie you could even
beat scissors
so here's what i need from you carson i
need it
i need a dub i need you to show i need a
dub from you
in consolation bracket minimum
you're being very you're being very kind
i i'm not being kind i just see it i
seize it
i looks at it and i knows what's gonna
happen you're gonna get a dub
i need to see one i need to see one just
make it happen
all right because you're making great
moves and i think they're intuitive
which is pretty insane
i think this is the one thing i'm going
to say is it was really impressive how
quickly you lost the first game
and not because you're bad but just
because you moved
so quickly it's like you spent zero you
had
way way less time used than grypics who
won the game
i think you took a minute 30 off your
clock that's impressive
that is an impressive thing to lose a 10
minute game in a minute 30.
uh so you could definitely draw it out
yeah that is a
problem cutie has uh her solution was
bringing hot cheetos
into the room i didn't foresee this i
don't know if you guys have any
experience bowties or
levy if there's a way to entertain
people while they're playing the game of
chess
well what i used to tell my students
when they would play too quickly
also they were seven years old was to
sit on their hands
in between moves and try to at least
count to 10
i'll be honest uh-huh well i look fun
i'm sorry carson i i i didn't mean it
like that
i mean ludwig just you win here one
lover yeah ever since
alex and jason got together j j schlotz
rubbed off he's like her
day jayshout's toxicness just oh it's so
obvious man i'm happy to get rid of
minks too don't
don't get me wrong but jeez okay like
griffix and i
missed out on some good gossip uh but
we'll we'll get we'll get filled in
later
yeah we'll fill you in guys and uh
listen we need
so here here's the redemption arc uh
carson you need to win
the the the constellation bracket and
then you need to drop some hot fire
about like the
the show announcement you know i've been
seeing on twitter some big moves
something's gotta something's gonna
happen that's gotta be the path
i'd talk about farts on twitter no no no
no you see like that he does not do that
i don't have it i wish i could tweet
about a fart and pull 50k
likes but i can't i can't do it
well either way gentlemen thank you for
your game today
uh grypics obviously good luck in the
championship bracket carson hopefully
you see a dub
in the constellation and uh we'll see
and uh thank you again boys thank you
game gripex
yeah good games man it was fun playing
yeah i was